okay we have been talking about whether
it's worthwhile for me to continue
appearing on Fox News as I did a couple
of weeks ago and despite being lit like
a white vampire compared to the very
orange counterparts that I had during
the appearance it really went pretty
well I think that the YouTube clip of my
appearance now has nearly five hundred
thousand views right something like that
and the question was is it worth me
appearing on fox news and i sort of
framed it to the audience as I'm up
against
usually a right an overt right winger
and also ganged up on by the host it's
mostly a right-wing audience I've got to
get down there and they make you get
there early and just sit there on it's a
waste of time in a lot of ways is it
worthwhile and the sometimes when we
pull just our audience we say you know
this is not really a representative
sample of the entire country because
it's just our audience yeah in this
particular case that's all I want to
hear from I want to hear from our
audience like does our audience think
that it's a good idea that it's
worthwhile for me to appear on fox news
yeah we don't really have the resources
to conduct scientific polling but no can
you know ask our audience and that's
what we do or even unscientific polling
like what Rasmussen does just kidding
just kidding so anyway what we did was
we put up a poll at the David Pakman
show YouTube channel at youtube.com
slash the david pakman show slash
community and the results are absolutely
overwhelming the question was is it
worth it for progressives to go on Fox
News 16,000 of you voted talk about
sample size 33 percent said I should
appear on Fox News because I might
persuade someone 36% said I should
appear on Fox News because dialogue is
always positive that is 69 percent of
our audience thinks that yes I should go
on Fox News 13 percent says no I
shouldn't do it because it's a set up
for me to fail and 18 percent said I
shouldn't do it because I'm not gonna
change anybody's mind overwhelming
nearly 7 and 10 of our viewers say it is
worth it to appear on Fox News that is
how I'm feeling as well now the only
question is are
gonna have me back because it's so funny
after these appearances right away
the booking producer it every time
without fail they email me and they say
that was so great we want to have you
back really soon and very often you just
never hear back and of course it's been
weeks and I haven't heard back I mean
that's just the boilerplate response but
how often would you even want to go on
fox news like do you want to go in
hannity show every week or is this just
every six months that you want to do
this I think going on hannity show every
week would be absolutely huge for the
david pakman show I would absolutely do
that if we could generate it you know a
500,000 view clip every week from a Fox
News appearance why wouldn't I do that
and our next poll is going to be do you
approve of producer Pat and all of the
answers are going to be different
variations of yes yeah well actually the
next poll is going to be how in favor
are you of polling on the david pakman
show youtube channel we're actually
gonna run that poll on the david pakman
show youtube channel and then we'll have
results from that if we're going mehta
with the next poll